[Musique]
là les amis on est arrivés patron europe
on le jeune mais que tu es pressé
nounours mes petits neveux ont été très
sages et j'ai hâte de leur porter un pro
de mieux à chacun je peux t'en mets pas
trop mais bien assez engendrant nounours
et cela en vite
pompom propos voilà votre attente ont
l'énergie au soir l'as musau j'ai abordé
pour ma petite patronales pour mon petit
nicolas deux jolies fleurs et les chers
petits neveux mais il m'a 30 dans
l'ordre au
[Musique]
est ce qu'ils ont été sages on est plus
nous ne haïssons sans médaille
alors tu as beau cadeau pour chacun
pour tout haut pour réduire et porte
enfants peuvent en cas je le retrouve
aux bonus et il tâtonne et pour jouer
kim aussi mais bien en avons la
farandole tout son sens en avant la
farandole de sommes dues aux astros
[Musique]
oh
et maintenant bonsoir petit cadavre et
qu'elle nageait ni cette oreille nous
allons un compact du pape rien n'est dit
cola au litchi qu'à la fin il me rend
pas couché ne vous inquiétez pas alors
en avant
[Musique]
bonsoir mon tuf un poteau métallique
oui
là dormi deux nuits à lomé de voeux à
vous maintenant voilà vous biberon
comme le petit l'ont faite de courage
[Musique]
et
ils sont merveilleux les neuf courses
j'espère que vous êtes aussi sache plus
d enfance aux autres ont tous plus
optionnel vu su petit ma chère soeur
emilia le roi donne une pro du cos en
effet nounours elle est très sympathique
taseer inclure port votre incorpore
allons en route
j'ai bien l'impression que nous irons
d'avoir bientôt
howie sommes fraude telle vente de
bonnes nuits des enfants à les rites
vous coucher et faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]
[Rires]